word is out
buffett is betting against the us for
the first time ever buffett is betting
against the us
for the first time ever he's been a long
critic of gold as an investment saying
it has
no utility in that the magical medal is
no match
for the american medal until now
berkshire hathaway okay just acquired 20
million 21 million shares of barrick
gold
which is worth 560
million dollars he just made a half a
billion dollar bet on gold
while selling shares of wells fargo
jpmorgan chase
the friday afternoon by the way he sold
1.75
shares of jp morgan chase and i'm sorry
of wells fargo he sold 1.39
of jp morgan chase buffett is betting on
gold
do you think he's just getting a little
too conservative or do you think he
knows something the rest of us don't
know hmm josh you go first on this one
because i know you're a big
golden big big metals guy
really really big metals and it's
because
i like to essentially hedge my well bro
look
i bought a bunch when it was about 14
bucks it got down as much as 12. i
bought a i mean
uh i don't want to say how much but i
bought a lot
um and i've seen a nice healthy increase
because we went from 14
to right now it's sitting somewhere
around 28 uh uh
this morning so and that's just been in
the last few months
but there's a lot of uncertainty right
and
the beautiful thing to me about about
metals is this
particularly silver when you start
looking at the fact that
there's there's physical silver and then
there's paper now
warren buffett's buying paper i'm i'm
personally not a fan of paper
and it's because this your metal is not
real
it's imaginary metal right so it can be
taken away an emp goes down they shut
down chicago
i mean there's a lot of stuff like but
it's kind of hard for him to buy this
much gold
because i don't even know that there's
this much gold in flipping existence in
the us
right now even if you went to fort knox
i think fort knox is probably empty
but that being said when you're buying
paper
gold all right or paper silver you're
buying something that has
zero backing there is not as much silver
as there is on paper because they i
think they can do 100x right pat
so if if you're trading you're trading
on 100x i buy physical silver because
should paper silver ever go away just
look at what physical silver's gonna do
it's gonna shoot 100x
okay um but as far as warren buffett
goes
what's he banking on though what's he
what's he banking on i'm so glad you
asked that question brother
i've been waiting all day to answer this
question i'm just kidding
um so but i did do a little research
here and are we even live right now
okay so this is actually the the power
of google
um do you know that the the ticker uh
you know this the stock exchange
the ticker for gold do you know what the
what the symbol is
what is that a aug right it's xau
it's not gold okay so just a little hot
tip for
what gold is is this barrick gold
company
so that's a great come up for barrick
gold their gold
so i did some i'm just thinking like why
after years and years and years you're
thinking about legacy planning and
everything he's ever said and i've i
i bet on american metal not this
precious metal
i have a different perspective i don't
think he's necessarily buying gold
i think he's buying the company it's
like back in the day you know who made
the money
in 1849 uh during the gold rush you know
who
actually made the money it wasn't the
company it was guys selling pickaxes
the guys that sold the freaking shovels
oh you go go ahead go find that gold
buddy
they're signed the guys that sold the
shovels the guys that set up the
restaurants the guys basically who are
capitalists saying
good luck finding that gold what i think
warren buffett is doing is he bet on
barrett gold and if you look at what
barrick gold is
our vision is to be the world's most
valued gold
mining business by finding and
developing
and owning the best assets with the best
people to deliver sustainable returns
for their owners or partners
so he's not buying gold he's buying the
company
he's basically saying you you people go
buy your gold
i'm gonna buy the company that gets all
the gold in your hands
so i don't think he's changing his
position i think he's basically saying
you guys running around buying your gold
i'm gonna go buy the company that's
mining the gold and then you do what you
want with your gold
because i think in this late in the game
i mean warren buffett's got to be 88 how
old is he
88 he's guessing late 80s okay and then
his boy
his homeboy charlie munger is what 90
99 and a half i mean why are these guys
still trading
yeah that's my point they're not doing
this
you're not they're not doing it for
money they're not they're not and
they're not he's not like reversing his
everything he's ever said on his legacy
and he's like oh you know guys
guys they're investing in the shovels
not the goal